so today we're going to talk about how
to lose more weight having a type of
thyroid condition okay so if you have a
slow thyroid this videos for you here's
the big problem when you do research on
a hypothyroid it's a bit complex because
you have Hashimoto's hypothyroid
condition you have nan Hashimoto's
hypothyroid condition you're given so
much advice it's almost impossible to
know what is the absolute important
things to know and what is the trivial
in this video we're gonna talk about the
absolute most important thing you need
to focus on to get results with weight
loss if you have a Hashimoto's type
thyroid case or just regular
hypothyroidism a few basics
you got the thyroid right here it's
located right in the bottom part of the
neck two and a half inches wide it
produces a hormone t4 okay the four
represents the number of iodine
molecules so you get four and then you
got this t3 over here right so T 4 t4 is
an inactive thyroid hormone it's not
active it doesn't really do much it's a
pre hormone your body strips off this
one of the iodine molecules and it
converts to t3 t3 is the active form of
thyroid hormone okay it's the thing that
goes into all the cells and speeds up
your metabolism as well as weight loss
and here's the most important thing to
get from this t4 to this t3 it has to be
converted okay
eighty percent of the conversion happens
through your liver and 20% happens
through the kidneys and this is really
important information because so many
people that have a hypo thyroid
condition have a fatty liver I mean it's
almost one for one if you have belly fat
chances are you have a fatty liver you
can get an ultrasound to find that out
but a fatty liver decreases the capacity
for that conversion so this will be your
focus to get the fat off the liver and
improve the function of the liver now it
could also be a problem with your
gallbladder it could be a problem with
not having a gallbladder it could be
cirrhosis it could be inflammation or
some damage in the liver but usually it
is a fatty
liver now you would think that all I
need to do is cut the fat out of my diet
and the fat will go away that's not how
it works and that's not which one to do
you do want to cut the carbs out okay
that's why I'm gonna recommend keto in a
minute fasting but you don't want to
start cutting down the fat and your diet
okay here are a few things to speed up
the process choline is one of the most
powerful nutrients to strip fat off your
liver very quickly you can get into
powder you can get into supplement I
recommend you get a high quality choline
and start taking that on a regular basis
that's going to assist this nutrient is
lipotropic it's it basically dissolves
fat and guess what food has the highest
amount of choline eggs egg yolks
interesting right so you don't want to
start giving up those foods that are
high in choline in fact if you have a
choline deficiency you could potentially
get a fatty liver next thing is selenium
okay why selenium selenium is also
involved in the conversion from t4 to t3
people that have a fatty liver are
nearly always deficient of selenium as
well as zinc we'll get to this in a
minute but selenium is an antioxidant so
it actually gets rid of the excess
hydrogen peroxide in your body let's
generate especially if you have
Hashimoto's hypothyroidism
so selenium is essential if you have
Hashimoto's this is really important
because it's it's going to help your
immune system okay so if you have
Hashimoto's you want to take some of
this as a supplement and you also want
to do more strict in a minute fasting
that's gonna drop the inflammation
because Hashimoto's is more of an immune
issue okay but it's also involved in the
conversion of t4 to t3 yes there's foods
high in selenium like Brazil nuts and
seafood but I don't recommend trying to
get all of your selenium from foods if
you're deficient you want to take it as
a supplement now I don't want to get
into the brands or dosages I would just
look online for something that looks
like it has a lot of good feedback on
other people that are getting good
results with it okay and then follow the
directions on the back of the bottle all
right next one is iodine iodine is part
of the raw material to build the thyroid
hormone and a lot of people are
deficient in iodine so I would get this
from sea kelp next one is zinc zinc is
really really important taking zinc will
help you in almost every single side
effect that hypothyroid produces like
for example loss of hair thinning hair
fatigue constipation zinc is good for
that zinc is very very very very good
for the thyroid it's also good for the
liver and if you have a fatty liver you
are going to be deficient in zinc okay
zinc is an oysters meat pumpkin seeds I
recommend getting it as a supplement so
these are the key things in addition to
keto and I F as your primary focus the
target inductance fatty liver to improve
the thyroid function thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos